Speaker 1: Donald Trump had a New Year's Eve
party at Mar a Lago.
On New Year's Eve, he announced that he would
be available to the media.
Barely any media showed up and Trump dodged
questions and generally seemed extremely confused.
We're going to look at a couple of clips just
to ring in the New Year together.
Trump was asked a question about a national
abortion ban.
He ignores it, calls on a different reporter.
Trump looks disoriented.
Melania looks miserable.
It's all just crazy for you.
Speaker 2: Mr. President.
Speaker 1: So he's asked, would you support
a national abortion ban?
He doesn't like the question.
He just calls on someone else.
Let's let's watch it again for you, for the
national average.
Speaker 2: Mr. President, the DOJ and FBI
have weaponized against you.
Will you commit to going after them in your
second term?
Speaker 1: This is a question he likes.
Speaker 2: I think it's a disgrace what's
happened with.
FBI with the weaponization of justice.
There's never been anything like this and
it is disgraceful.
And thank you for that question and.
Speaker 1: That question he appreciates.
At another moment, he's asked about Ron DeSantis
and then he talks about the border of Ukraine
and Russia.
It doesn't make any sense what he's saying.
It just totally confused, garbled speech.
I do apologize also because the audio isn't
great on this segment, but I think we'll be
able to hear it.
Speaker 2: The question is.
Unidentified: Will the former.
No.
Speaker 1: He's just ignoring the few questions
he's getting.
Half of them he doesn't like.
Speaker 2: Involved with any more than taking
place right now.
He's really turning around and killing a lot
of people, but.
Unidentified: Hopefully they're getting ready
to work on the Ukraine and Russia.
Speaker 2: We have to have that.
We have a strong border.
Very important to understand what happens
now, I mean, very gravely here and the fact
that we've got to do better than waiting for
you for a national audience.
So this.
Speaker 1: Is a section from before.
Speaker 2: The DOJ and FBI have weaponized
against you.
Were you going after them in your second term?
I think it's a disgrace what's happened with
the FBI, with the weaponization of justice.
There's never been anything like this.
And this is disgraceful.
And thank you for that question, I.
Well, I.
We're really.
Speaker 1: All right.
Anyway, as you can see, almost no media showed
up.
You see a microphone from O.J. and there and
just really, really failing.
And then inside the party, Donald Trump offered
the following inspirational and uplifting
message going into the new year.
Speaker 2: We're watching the war raging.
We're watching nuclear weapons talk about
it all the time.
We're watching inflation going through the
roof.
All of these things that we're watching and
so unnecessary and so sad to see.
Now we have airports and a people can fly.
The only good thing is, frankly, from the
standpoint we needed some seats, so we lost
50, we sold about 200 extra.
So but it's it's sad what people can come
from New York to Florida and the airports
are like we're like a third world country.
Speaker 1: There you go.
An inspirational message of peace and love.
We are like a third world country and people
can't fly anymore.
So, listen, it's going we're sort of poking
fun at this because it's ridiculous and hilarious
and pathetic, but I have no idea what to expect
for 2023.
If you came to me and you said, Sir, by the
end of 2023, will Trump even still be a candidate
for the Republican nomination?
I don't know where I would bet on an even
money bet.
I don't know if I take the bet that Trump
will still be a candidate by the end of this
year or that he will not.
Very difficult to say.
Things are odd, things
are strange, and we're just getting started.